so whatever happens with nick foles yeah
we know in chicago
the top two options will be andy dalton
justin fields
in that order at least for now and
look matt nagy i believe continues to be
committed
to the kansas city model from 2017
even though the circumstances are
dramatically different
yeah the equity that the starting
quarterback has is
dramatically reduced andy dalton has no
history with the bears
at all but nagi likes the idea i believe
i've heard this and this best explains
his public comments he likes the idea
of giving justin fields time to learn
from the number two position like
patrick mahomes did in 2017 now is it a
full season
or in my home's case it was up until a
meaningless week 17 game
but and we've talked before about
looking at the schedule maybe week 10 is
the sweet spot where fields takes over
but
nagi seems bound to determine chris to
carry andy dalton as the starter not
just
into training camp but through training
camp through the preseason
into week one of the regular season and
maybe beyond and
and and that he i mean unless a a big
curve ball is coming or
justin fields is so dramatically better
than andy dalton in camp that
that neggie can't justify holding fields
down
it's going to be dalton yeah no it's
going to be dalton to me it's just a
question of whether like does
fields impress enough and have a grasp
enough of the offense
to maybe infiltrate the lineup or the
starting 11
in certain spots early on in the season
to me that's where it is
see where it's different a little bit
than the kansas city model like you're
bringing up
is you know of course in kansas city we
had a team that was
in the playoffs and a quarterback that
was playing at a pretty high level
especially when it came to stats and
quarterback rating and things like that
so i think and then it was patrick
mahomes who nobody knew about
really at the time and he came from
texas tech
so there wasn't the public push and
pressure it was like well we got this
gunslinger from texas tech that andy
reid likes
you know nobody knew what he was about
to be um
uh the flip coin or flip side to that is
it's a little different here
we know what andy dalton is he's not
playing to the level that alex smith was
playing when they drafted patrick
mahomes
you know the team itself i don't think
the bears are at the level the chiefs
were
and m many more people there's more
pressure behind the justin field
situation yes there's the trade up
but like we've talked about he's been
you know the big guy on campus
on the number two school in the country
you know for the last two years in a row
so everybody's seen him and hey this
guy's a star and when he's on the field
they win
and i think that adds pressure to the
situation for the bears and i think it's
gonna
lead to more of a clamoring from the fan
base and everything like that
and even within the locker room when
justin fields shows a little talent
those guys again they're gonna go wait
we've seen andy dahl we know what he is
that's cool that's great
but man fields he's got something so i i
do think training camp can maybe dictate
in pre-season if he has a package of
plays we've talked about a little bit
mike maybe early in the year
to at least get him in get him playing
get him some experience and get him
going that way
and the chiefs at least had a history of
pretty good
quarterbacks dating back to len dawson
and they had joe montana now
of you know apologies to todd blackledge
but
they they have had guys that they can
look to
sure trent greene the bears haven't yeah
the bears have the bears are still
desperate
for their nexid luckman so i think
that's part of it too it all goes into
the blender and it makes it different it
does create an anticipation that fields
is going to be the guy and again we
can't get past the fact that if the
locker room is like what the hell is
wrong with nagi
why isn't he going with fields i think
that moves the needle that way
i agree as well it's like russell wilson
in 2012
people say it was brave for pete carroll
to go with wilson over matt flynn after
they gave matt flynn all that money no
the brave thing would have been to go
with flynn
because everyone knew that wilson was
the guy it was the easy decision
for carol to make here's fields talking
about
his own personal timeline and listen
carefully to what he says
about help that he's gotten from andy
dalton
my job is strictly to get better be the
best quarterback i can be and
uh you know help my team win so that's
that's what i'm gonna do whether it's
starting whether it's
you know sitting um i'm gonna do
whatever uh
is but that's that's gonna help us win
so yeah if i've learned
a lot of things i i couldn't even name
off a few things but i mean he's talked
to
me a lot uh i actually went to dinner
with him and his wife so
we talked a lot there and um kind of
just his background and stuff like that
their story but
i mean andy and they've been awesome to
mean probably bigger than you guys even
even though um just just yeah i mean
andy's
completely taking me under his wing uh
any question that i have for him
uh he's he's gonna answer and even when
i'm throwing i think there was one day
out
after ota is always throwing extra after
packs and he stayed out there
specifically just to you know
uh see maybe what i was doing wrong and
he was just trying to help help me out
so i mean he's been a huge help for sure
[Music]
um chris i got to give you credit maybe
this is the influence that i've had on
you in a negative way but
uh you you spotted
what was embedded in that last part the
idea that
andy dalton was spotting
things that justin fields was doing
wrong
um i don't know that that's helped
justin
and maybe a little passive aggressive
hey kid you got a lot to learn
and hey kid maybe you got some stuff in
your throwing motion
that's a little funky like you know just
look for a picture of justin fields
throwing the ball that elbow
is aiming sky high and that's something
you've had concerns about
for a while right yeah it definitely is
you know i mean
hey one first off you know justin fields
he's talented
i want to make this clear mike just
because i think people think i'm a hater
on them and i'm not i'm rooting for him
you can see there handles himself the
right way got a good way about him
there's no doubt it's cool that andy
dalton's doing that it really is andy
dalton showing like his maturity and
he's comfortable where he is in life in
the nfl and everything like that
that he'll that he's willing to take a
guy like that underneath you know
underneath his wing like that to a
degree
but yeah i mean again that does worry me
and you're right like any picture you
bring up with justin fields and i have
people all the time trying to send me
pictures of other quarterbacks and go oh
look
his elbow's up and i go yeah but they
got to that position in a different way
and that's where it's different it's not
start from the elbow and do those things
but nonetheless it caught my attention
yeah
because there there has to be
that concern or at least that work going
on behind the scenes with justin fields
to clean that up well
listen i'm not like a know-it-all but i
mean anybody you talked to in football
had a little concern about justin
field's motion and his mechanics and
throwing
so that has to be worked on andy dalton
is pretty consistent not going to wow
you
with everything he does throwing the
football but he does have pretty good
mechanics never been like
totally inaccurate has control of the
football
i'm sure he can point him in the right
direction and give him a few things to
think about
it's just going to be can they beat
these things out of them these bad
habits
and i doubt but they can do that by the
start of like this season
but if he continues to work on it maybe
by year two it can
be gone by the wayside and he can kind
of readjust his motion altogether
and i still continue to wonder whether
or not
changes can be made yeah
to something that a guy has been doing
his life
i remember that tim tebow that was the
first time in the 20 years and it was
about 10 years ago that i've been
doing this for a living that it
crystallized
you got a guy who's obsessed with
changing his throwing motion because his
prior
motion and it was different because his
took too long for the ball to get out
fields can still whip it yes he can
just that elbow as you've said it messes
up accuracy because you're working
through it and it's not smooth it's not
efficient and he but even though he does
get through it fast
tebow had that long catapult
you know hold the ball down near the
ground and and it just gives the
defensive backs extra time to see what's
coming
and and the narrative prior to the 2010
draft was he's changing his motion he's
changing his motion
changing his motion and everything he
did it was a different motion and then
he went out and played and it was the
old motion
you can't you can't get what you've
always done
right once the switch is on and you're
in the middle of it
and you're just going on instinct your
instinct hasn't changed
you can say i'm doing it this way i'm
doing it this way over and over again
you go out in the game and you're gonna
do it the way you've always done it it
is really
i mean you're right i i and and i'm not
arguing against you you know most people
can't
adjust the way they throw or do those
things
natural ones can people who are
naturally
gifted throwers they can tweak and
change the motion
over time justin feels i do think has an
enough
natural aspect to to break some of these
habits
but it's one of those things mike like
you talked like you're talking about
here just to hammer home that point
you know this is something hey this is
what the sims family does we worked with
a lot of quarterbacks college nfl
high school whatever and when a guy
really has a
like a technical flaw you know usually
my father is going to say something like
hey when the season's over you need to
kind of come see us like within the
first two weeks this can't be like we're
gonna start diving in this to may
we gotta start like in january and we're
gonna have to like
get the new mechanics and techniques
down and we're gonna have to get 10 to
15
000 reps doing it because that's the
only way you're going to beat it into
your brain to make it
second nature to where it doesn't go
revert back to the old motion to like
you're talking about mike because that's
what does happen
and that's where you know it's going to
be critical so i don't know how much he
can change
right now he can tweak and stay on some
things
but you know hopefully off the after the
off season
he can work on it even more and and
continue to grow and kind of clean up
some of these issues we talk about
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports